okay baby let's try this one
come
you can wear one of these outfits
tonight
yeah
of course i want her to be happy about
what i'm wearing
look at the difference you even have a
body let me know at the same time
the only thing is
since i've been out of work for several
months now i wasn't planning to
like buy a ton of stuff you even look
like a completely different person i
love it
all right
as long as you're happy
okay
now it's time to pay
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay baby where's your wallet it's
incredible how much 500 12
500 big ones
um
yeah i'm sorry i
i didn't notice so much i i think i
might have to come back and buy these
another time
what
i'm serious
really
yeah
i don't want to spend 500 on clothes
right now
no no
why should i tell her
i don't know
i know she wants me to improve my look
but
i feel really uncomfortable to be put on
the spot to spend this kind of money
right now
500 in panama is 500 us dollars and i
don't care what country i'm in i am not
going to spend 500 on clothes
perfect
no problem okay okay
sorry
so let's go
i can tell jasmine's upset
i'm a little shocked because i know she
knows my situation right now
i know she's trying to get me to spend
money on myself and not her but i don't
want her to see me as a walking cash
machine you know
i don't want her to think of me like
that
[Music]
you